Speaker 1: All right, let's get into the
Friday feedback, a.k.a. Friday feedback.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
Sometimes we will highlight for your viewing
and listening pleasure or displeasure
a Facebook message that we receive or
a YouTube comment that we spot or could really
come from anywhere. Yeah, let's just get right
into it. First message today came from Sheryl via
Facebook. Sheryl says hi you're sir are and idiot
when told by our auto reply that I am unable to
reply to every message individually. Sheryl added
Yes, tell them to get his facts right. We here in
Florida love our governor and the job he's doing.
So pull your head out of your ass and get someone
else besides Ruth left wing nut to rebut her. I
don't have the slightest idea what Sheryl is
talking about. And interestingly, we get a ton
of messages like this, and it really is unclear
to me, like, I know that it's not that these folks
aren't native English speakers. I know that that's
not the case. Sometimes out of morbid curiosity,
we will look and it'll be like, Oh, no, Sheryl was
born in, you know, Jupiter, Florida, or something
like that and is is a native English speaker. So
are these typing problems, are these voice to text
issues? Why is it that the emails and messages
I get from right wingers are so overwhelmingly
disastrous when it comes to syntax and format
and everything? I don't know. I don't know.
Vivian collect. Cee Lo says I dare David Pakman
to have an intellectual conversation livestream
with Russell Brand and see how he holds up.
Maybe a little humbling would do him some good,
but only big, brave people rise up to a
challenge like this, so it won't happen.
I want to explain to Vivian and
others a little something. Okay?
I get emails all the time saying, Well, if you
think Russell Brand is so wrong about stuff,
have him on your show. If you think Ben SHAPIRO
is wrong, have him on your show, you won't
because you're scared. We invite all of these
people. It is they who don't want to be on. Now,
in their defense, maybe my show is too small.
Potatoes are small bananas for them. Fine. But
it is not because I'm scared that they aren't on
this show. It's because they don't respond to our
requests to be on. Russell Brand is welcome any
time. And Vivian, it's not because of me that he's
not here. It's because he doesn't want to do it,
which is his right. I don't think I have a right
to debate Russell Brand the way some of these
right wingers say, but Russell's welcome anytime.
The anti-trans rhetoric is very strong among
the right wing elements of our audience right
now. Christopher put on YouTube quote, I
mean, talking about my daughter, I guess,
I mean, if you want your daughter to have to use
the same bathroom as a six foot three bearded,
muscular man, more power to you. The rest of
us will make sure to protect our daughters,
wives, mothers and other biological women in our
lives. You know, when I see something like this.
I really wonder. Is Christopher really a dad?
Like where my mind really goes to is to that,
because I have to tell you, I know so many
people who have daughters, myself included,
and the trans bathroom issue quite literally never
enters my mind. Now, I understand right now my
daughter's two feet tall. She can't even walk. So
the idea that she's going to end up in a bathroom
by herself or whatever. Like, I get that it's not
an issue. But even when I think about the next
five years, the next ten years and the things
that, you know, going to school and travel and
camp and all these different things, the trans
bathroom issue doesn't even enter my mind as an
issue. So it makes me question like, what's going
on in Christopher's life? That this is really what
he's thinking about. Or is it all made up? Does
Christopher not really have a daughter? Cuba.
On, I guess, CRT, Marxism, trans stuff. Cuba
says he was right. It's taught. My daughter is
in middle school in California and I've seen her
homework assignments when I was in high school. I
had quite a few Marxist teachers. This is America.
We believe in capitalism and free market. If you
don't like it, move to Cuba. Ask any Cuban
American why their family left and they'll
tell you the horrors of socialism. Listen,
I'm the wrong guy to make this argument too.
I have never been a defender of the Castro
regime. I wanted normalization of relations
with Cuba because the embargo was hypocritical. It
was a double standard. And I try to avoid absurd
double standards. But that was for the benefit
of the Cuban people. It was not because I am a
defender of the Castro regime. So I am very well
aware that there is this overreaction among many
Cuban-Americans. Cuban-Americans are one of
the few groups of of Hispanic Americans that
regularly vote for Republicans. And part of it
is because of their aversion to Cuba and the
Castro regime. They see even like food stamps as
socialism or Marxism, which of course, it's not.
So I'm the wrong guy to do the go back to Cuba
thing, too, by the way. I've never been to Cuba
anyway, but I would be interested in visiting.
User one who sleeps not posted on Reddit and
this is an interesting topic is David putting too
much emphasis on Ron Desantis's lack of charisma?
Pacman is frequently referred to the Santos's
abysmal lack of charisma and pointed out that
he certainly doesn't seem to have the same
energy Trump had in 2016. Seems true enough,
but I wonder if it really matters. Art depicting
of Trump often slims him down to a ridiculous
degree. His stream of consciousness bellyaching
at rallies has been hailed as some of the greatest
speeches of all times by his followers. His
extensive and obvious political failures have been
recast as Machiavellian 4D Chess moves to trip
up and ensnare his enemies. Evangelical preachers
have praised this lecher and thief as a true man
of God, or the tool by which God will restore the
country to greatness. I don't think the Santos's
lack of charisma will matter one bit. People see
what they want to see, and I don't doubt their
means. And leaders will help them see DeSantis
in an implausibly good light. I don't think so.
And here's why. The reason that everything Trump
does is seen as a great thing by Trump's
followers is that many of Trump's followers
are people who never followed the political
system, and many of them never even voted until
Trump arrived on the political scene. They are a
different sort of voter, and the DeSantis voter,
as I currently understand the DeSantis voter to
be, is someone who is more engaged with politics
and is a little more connected to reality than the
average Trump voter and wants something different
than Trump. So my opinion right now in this could
change is that the average DeSantis supporter or
potential DeSantis supporter would be much more
influenced by the reality of DeSantis and would
be less willing to recast every aspect of DeSantis
as a positive trait the way that Trump supporters
are. Because fundamentally, Trump supporters
and non MAGA Republicans are very different
groups. I want to hear from you on that. Maybe I'm
wrong. Maybe my perspective is wrong. Demon King
commented on YouTube. As a transwoman, I just
don't feel safe anymore. Living in a less than
progressive state is taxing. It's a shame that
I have to carry defense items just to feel safe.
Thank you, David, for always reporting the truth,
as you always do. They will not stop until they
have something else to grift to. History is unkind
to anyone who chooses to try to suppress anyone's
rights. Well, you know, I am reminded of Arnold
Schwarzenegger's recent 12 minute video that
he did last week or the week before, and he says
in it. The people who try to deny others rights,
they end up being losers in history. And he talks
about his own Nazi sympathizing father. This is
Arnold Schwarzenegger. Check out the video if you
haven't seen it. And so I do maintain hope. And
quite frankly, I do think it's likely that the
anti trans people will end up losers. I mean,
listen, the anti-gay people have basically ended
up losers. Gay marriage is now legal nationally.
It's more acceptable culturally than at any point
in American history of the modern political era.
So the anti-gay people are increasingly losers.
They're both losers legislatively, and they're
just losers when you you know, at this point, it
is far more common that if someone just casually
uses the F-word to refer to gay people, most
of the people around them are going to look at
them like, what? That dude, what are you talking
about by using that word? So the anti-gay people
are increasingly losers. My hope is that Arnold is
correct and that the anti trans people also will
end up being losers in history will be unkind
to them. But the concern is in the short term,
they can really make a lot of people's lives very
miserable. And that is what I want to prevent.
But very good and sad comment there. William
commented about my practice of removing the
free Bibles left in hotel rooms from hotel
rooms when I travel. William said, David,
I understand you have a right to remove a Bible
from your hotel room, but I'm curious why, if it's
in a drawer, I think he means drawer. If it's in
a drawer out of sight, how is it offensive? Well,
I never said it was offensive. I understand you
are of Jewish faith. Are you not allowed by your
faith to have the Bible in your personal space? It
is not a question of what Judaism allows me to do.
I'm not even a religious person. Here's the way
I see it. When I. Rent a hotel room or, you know,
reserve stay in a hotel room. I am looking to
stay in a room that provides me a comfortable bed.
Maybe free coffee, a TV wi fi, a
clean and comfortable bathroom,
a quiet room far from the elevator so I can get a
good night's sleep, you know, whatever. I am not
looking for, nor do I consider it something that
is appropriate to provide me a hotel room. That is
all those things. Plus, it provides Christian
reading materials. First of all, why? Why
Christian reading materials? But. But why not some
other? It doesn't make any sense. I'm not looking
for a hotel room. That is all of the things I
mentioned and gives me Christian reading material.
So what I do, I'm not mad at anybody. I'm not
looking to have anybody arrested. I'm not looking
to have anybody insulted is I just put that free
Bible left by the Gideon's out in the hallway or
in the recycling bin. I'm not offended. It's not
that I'm not allowed. It's just I'm not looking
to stay in rooms that have been pre-populated
with the allegedly sacred texts of one of a
thousand religions. It's just not what I'm looking
for. So I just do my quiet thing and I go, okay,
I'll just take that out. The towels, I want the
free soaps. I'm looking for a nice conditioner
to try to get my hair under control. Great. But
the Bible is just not part of what I'm looking
for in a hotel room. So if I happen to see it, I
don't go looking for it. If I happen to see it,
I just put it out in the hallway like a room
service tray. A couple people wrote to me and
were offended. Many people wrote to me and said
they do the same thing. One person canceled their
paid subscription. I'm not going to hide from
you. That that's something I do If I remember,
and I'll be honest, many times I stay in
a hotel one night for some work thing. I
don't even come across the Bible. I don't even
check. It was probably there. It's no big deal.
It's just not a big deal. Everybody remain calm.
Please. We have a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up it. Join Pacman Dotcom. Replace the guy
who canceled his membership because I put the
Bible in the hallway and you can use the coupon
code. 24 starts now to get yourself a discount.